[Music]
the prime minister and the government
collectively
um are guilty of my view of serial
incompetent
we can see that uptick we need to
control it the virus
the the reality is there will be
stronger enforcement more powers for the
police
how would you describe the state of race
relations in america
right now pathetic there's no other word
it's pathetic
eight years later then what happened it
just kind of came up on my phone
last night and he replied to it and i
didn't even
remember the conversation that we had if
i'm honest
labor at a time like this will act in
the national interest
we will be a constructive opposition
we will support whatever reasonable
steps are necessary
to protect lives and protect our nhs
but i also want to say this there should
be nothing inevitable
about a second lockdown it would be a
sign of government failure
not an act of god it would take an
immense toll
on people's physical and mental health
and on the economy
i interviewed today circus starmer
the labour leader i asked him about
kovid i asked him about boris johnson's
leadership
secure big announcements on new coved
restrictions yesterday
different leaders of different nations
have gone in different directions
do you think boris johnson went far
enough there are obviously different
rules now in england scotland
and wales and one of my criticisms of
the prime minister is that he hasn't
held the four nations
um together barely had meetings with the
leaders in
the devolved administrations and it
would be far better if there's one set
of rules across the whole of the united
kingdom what's your view on households
on households i mean we're supporting
the government's rule of six
obviously we'll have to keep it under
close review but i am conscious
of not trying to put up a different set
of propositions
to the government the furlough scheme
you want more support
for people if they can't get back to
work as the government is introducing
new
health restrictions it's phasing out
economic support
businesses now as the result of these
new restrictions
are going to be put under huge strain
and you owe it to them to put a support
mechanism in place and the government
really should have done that yesterday
let's move on to your speech yesterday
you talked about the prime minister's
character in your speech you said of
boris johnson
that while he was writing flippant
columns about bendy bananas
i was defending victims and prosecuting
terrorists while he was being sacked by
a newspaper for making up quotes
i was fighting for justice and the rule
of law that they're quite
personal attacks you didn't used to make
such personal attacks from what's
changed
boris johnson and i are very two very
different individuals and i think
um it's very important that people see
and understand that
the labour party is under new leadership
it's for me to set out
how i will lead the labour party that's
what i was doing yesterday
but you're playing the man not the ball
i mean you're criticizing him personally
rather than the policies aren't you
well character matters at a time like
this people looking to the prime
minister
um and they they absolutely need the
reassurance
that he and the government are able to
do what's necessary
to ensure the infection rate goes down
and to do what's necessary to avoid mass
unemployment so
at this time above all else character
matters but in your speech yesterday you
said
he's just not up to the job so you do
think he's a bad leader
the prime minister and the government
collectively um
are guilty in my view of serial
incompetence they've been 12
u-turns now i'm quite prepared to accept
that a government will make mistakes in
a pandemic like this and one or two
u-turns
are probably a sign of a government
listening and then changing but when
you've got
12 in a row the only conclusion is
serial incompetence
you've got a clear strategy when it
comes to boris jones and the
conservatives but what about the snp
what's your position do you rule out
another referendum in scotland
we will be making the argument going
into that election next may that this is
not the time for another divisive
independence referendum
tougher lockdown restrictions in england
have been introduced by the prime
minister
all an attempt to prevent a second wave
of coronavirus
in a speech to the country boris johnson
warned that the government
will go further and even deploy the
military if
people do not obey the new rules
foreign secretary is with us now mr rob
good morning calling in the army what's
all that about
we're taking series of targeted
proportionate focus steps
because although we've made huge
progress since the peak of the virus in
march
we can see that uptick and we need to
control it uh the virus
the the reality is there will be
stronger enforcement more powers for the
police
higher levels of fines mainly for the
small minority
who haven't complied always with the
rules we don't want them to blow it for
the vast majority of people and end up
in a second lockdown
the issue with the army is as throughout
this pandemic they've been used to
backfill or to support
for example local authorities with
testing delivery of ppe
and if they can relieve any capacity for
the police to do the very difficult job
that they've done incredibly well
they'll be there to do that okay so not
on the streets as it were
i think the suggestion being put around
by john ashworth that they're going to
be out patrolling is
uh frankly scaremongering it does look
as though this i don't know if you saw
the latest ugov pole that with the snap
pill that was out last night public
supports the new covert restrictions
but almost half then that they don't go
far enough also
the um developed nations don't think
that they go far
enough what else is in the arsenal i
don't think we're going to speculate
about what further could be
done but the but the reality is they'll
be more intrusive
we could end up in a national lockdown
that's what we want to evolve
to avoid and let's hope that we can get
through the winter months if we
take these measures if everyone plays by
the rules we go into christmas not
needing to go into that national
lockdown with all the impact on society
and families
but also the damage it would do to
businesses the prime minister in his
recorded address to the four nations
last night
said that we have succeeded before one
wonders how
one of the world's worst death tolls can
be seen as success
well we've succeeded in getting grip of
this deadly virus
we've uh protected well we
we've come through that major peak that
if you look at the hospitalization rate
the fatality rate
we've we've got that right down but we
don't want to see an
uptick in the number of cases lead to
that trajectory going back up
and i think we've got now the measures
in place to make sure we can
we don't lose the sacrifices we don't
lose the gains that we've made and we've
also got schools open we've got
businesses open we've got the
hospitality sector open
yes people bristle a little bit about
these extra restrictions the
10 pm limits on bars and restaurants but
that's in order that we can
bank the gains we've made move forward
in a short footed and safe and
responsible way
not end up in a second lockdown but
there's no there's no silver bullet here
um okay and we are deriving different
lessons from different aspects of the
evidence
and indeed the international practice
yeah but five percent
of cases were from food outlets and that
does include pubs and restaurants
well i'm not sure quite the data you've
got i trust it i know you're reading out
faithfully
but we're looking at the whole range of
evidence that we've got
including where there's been upticks in
the virus in the localized areas how we
got back control on a personal level are
you worried about
um the flu vaccine are you going to have
a flu vaccine this this winter
yes absolutely as soon as possible okay
uh are you worried about catching
booked in for one on friday oh are you
um maybe i'll have one as well
um as a result of that i'll say the
foreign secretary says he's having one
so i'm going to have one are you worried
about
catching covert have you had it already
um i i haven't had an antibody test but
every time i've had symptoms i've either
self-isolated and then had a test
and so who knows um i mean before the
the lockdown in march in in
in in back in february i had some of the
symptoms and you never quite know
from the swab tests looking really
poorly in the house of commons well but
look i've been tested a number of times
including when i went to the states and
i'm free of code
the prime minister told a meeting at the
un's general assembly that the uk
will co-host a virtual summit in
december to encourage countries to do
more to tackle carbon emissions
well let's just speak to the author and
climate activist naomi klein who
joins us from canada how do nations
around the world prepare for the
environmental challenges
that we are all currently facing well
the most important thing
we need to do is cut emissions as
radically as we possibly can um because
there's there are levels of climate
disruption that there's no preparing for
um that really make this planet
uninhabitable and this is what
scientists have been telling us about
the urgency of keeping
warming levels below 1.5 degrees celsius
and so we need rapid decarbonization we
need to get to the post
carbon economy as quickly as possible
but
as we know climate change is already
here and so
um there are all kinds of things that we
need to do
in order to make the shocks that are
already coming
less severe so you know where i am just
a few days ago we were choked in
wildfire smoke
um and and we know that there are some
things that we can do
to reduce the severity of wildfires i
mean
the driver of this is heat the driver of
this is drought um
but part of what we've done wrong is we
have
not listened to what indigenous people
in this part of the world have known for
a long time
which is that we shouldn't be
suppressing all fire that some kinds of
fire are actually really important
for controlling these kinds of
out-of-control
wildfires so we need controlled burns
and part of this actually is centers
around respecting indigenous land right
so that's just one example of course you
know we all know
the kind of engineering responses sea
walls all of this
but it's also about our relationship
with the land around us and whether we
are going to cling to this myth that we
can control the natural world or whether
we're going to try to
support natural cycles of renewal and
also just kind of take up less space as
humans
because we've been sprawling into
wilderness in all kinds of ways
and closer to home here in the uk
millions of people face the prospect of
an
uncertain employment future you've
written extensively about a green new
deal
is it now time for governments to start
taking this seriously because there has
been a lot of talk about it
in recent years well it was time a long
time ago but there's nothing like the
present
um you know if we had listened to
scientists if we had been listened
listening to uh countries that were
demanding a marshall plan for planet
earth more than a decade ago
like bolivia uh we wouldn't be where we
are now
um but absolutely you know the the book
that i wrote
um that is that that is just coming out
now in the uk and paperback it came out
a year ago
uh and it's calling for a green new deal
and when that happened
i got a lot of pushback from people who
said look the economy is going great
um the the original new deal was
introduced in the depths of the great
depression
by franklin delano roosevelt primarily
as a jobs program as a way to create
millions of jobs for people
you know who couldn't feed their
families and so a year later
i think the arguments for a green new
deal look very different because of
course we are still in the climate
in the grips of the climate crisis and
it has deepened as it does
um but we are also now in a situation
where no one can claim that the economy
is going well
and we need that kind of jobs
program that kind of economic stimulus
that the green new deal is modeled after
the crisis we're facing is like nothing
we have seen since the great depression
so i think the argument for a green new
deal
on the economic side on the job site as
you say
is much much stronger
[Music]
the mayor of louisville in kentucky has
declared a state of emergency ahead of a
looming decision in the case of briana
taylor
her death at the hands of police one of
many that sparked protests across the
u.s
and the rise in prominence of armed
militia groups
right first rank take two steps forward
this is the nfac
armed aggrieved and increasingly visible
y'all know what our rules of engagement
are right we don't point out weapons
that nobody
unless they point them at you in an
america
where racial tension is raging
the group is exclusively black
and grandmaster jay is the closely
guarded
enigmatic leader he's agreed to speak
with us from what he calls
a safe house the group says that it's
not made up of
protesters or demonstrators that it is
a black militia and we're about to meet
the leader
grandmaster jay he's told us to come to
a secluded
location where he hopes we won't be seen
one of my jobs is to protect the
identity
of our members that is why i am the only
one that speaks for the nfac you have
folks that are veterans there are
corporate execs that are
members that don't want to have to deal
in their personal life
with the pressures of being a part of
this organization
we're going to prove to the world that
we can be just as organized
just as disciplined just as well armed
just as determined as any standing
military of any government
not as some mob in the streets that gets
together on the weekends to call
themselves patriots
why do you think it's necessary to carry
weapons
i'm not going to answer that question
unless you ask that question of every
other race that carries weapons
every other civilization that has gone
into other countries with weapons
the police carry weapons weapons were
invented to defend
oneself so it is only common sense that
we carry weapons
to defend ourselves it is not a question
it is a necessity
how would you describe the state of race
relations in america
right now pathetic there's no other word
it's pathetic it has deteriorated uh to
a to a place that is reminiscent
of the early 60s it is reminiscent of
jim crow it is reminiscent
of the the lynch era it is reminiscent
of the the days of the klu klux klan
there's a growing face-off between armed
groups in the u.s
but nfac insists unlike others they
haven't committed any crimes everything
that
that we've done has been within the
confines of the constitution
the day that the nfac steps over the
line
it will be because the line was already
stepped over for us
first the black lives matter movement is
vast
and varied but he doesn't identify with
it
it has been infiltrated by people like
antifa
uh anarchists people who come in just to
destroy not to achieve
anything many in the very broad network
firmly reject that claim but one thing
the groups share
is a desire to end racial injustice
[Music]
now sir howard evans the pioneering
newspaper editor has died at the age of
92.
harry haven't edited the sunday times
for 14 years and led a number of famous
groundbreaking campaigns including the
investigation that exposed the birth
defects caused by the drug
thalidomide well joining me now is
the author and former sunday times
columnist and friend
of sir harold evans robert harris why
was harry evans so important to
journalism
he was a newspaper man to his fingertips
he failed the 11 plus and went to work
on a local paper in the north of england
and from there he gradually worked his
way up he absolutely understood the nuts
and bolts of the industry
and he combined this with a kind of
campaigning mentality in particular
uh uh uh he liked to use the newspaper
to help the lives of his readers uh and
then when he uh
came to london and edited the sunday
times he brought the same
campaigning mentality down here uh
it's also worth pointing out for for
people that he changed the way
newspapers looked he was a brilliant
on-the-page designer and he made the
sunday times a visually very impactful
paper along with the stories he ran on
things like thalidomide
and then he went to america in in the
1980s which was
a bit of a surprise for someone who was
such a kind of an englishman and a
northerner why did he do that
well he was fired i suppose is the main
reason he'd been a very successful
editor of the sunday times
legendary probably the greatest
newspaper editor in britain since the
war
then he made the mistake of going to the
times that which didn't suit him at all
he was uh i wouldn't say harry had a
chip on his shoulder but he was very
much from an
ordinary stock always spoke with a
northern accent with a railway man stun
uh he didn't get on with murdoch he uh
was fired he was married to uh
an american journalist tina brown very
famous in her own right
and so he made a new life for himself at
55 he went off to
new york and and had a completely
successful career as a publisher and
that's really where i got to know him
because in 1991 he bought my first novel
and uh published it brilliantly i think
on the day that he dies one should
remember that he was a very inspiring
man
he was a bundle of energy and enthusiasm
he always you know you always started
smiling when you saw harry he was he was
a terrific guy and it's very hard to
believe even though obviously he lived
to a good
age of 92 it's very hard to believe that
he's no longer around
he liked to make mischief he believed in
facts
and responsibility of the press but he
also believed that the press's job
was to cause a bit of trouble for those
in authority
and my god he certainly did quite a lot
of that
eight years ago my next guest made a
prediction on twitter that actor ryan
reynolds
would one day leave the hollywood hills
and come to wrexham in north wales
why not at now he's in talks to invest
in wrexham football club so did he get
the idea from her
let's take a look back at that twitter
exchange in 2012
lois morris responded to her friend on
twitter saying
you never know when ryan reynolds is
going to turn up in wrexham
yesterday ryan reynolds replied to her
tweeting
i've waited eight years to respond to
this tweet
and lyce morris joins me now from
camardon just take us back
2012 you're having some twitter banter
with one of your friends how did it
start
um followed was just like a short kind
of like a banterous kind of conversation
as you said
and we were just talking about kind of
uni modules and stuff like that
and my friend shannon the one that i was
speaking to she was
doing art in college and she mentioned
that she was doing like a life drawing
kind of module in her class
and we just kind of mentioned don't be
funny you know it would be a lot better
if it was ryan reynolds that was the
model
um and basically yeah she kind of said
oh i'll let you know if he's
around in wrexham and i just said oh
well you know
i'd take that course and you never know
if he'd turn up and then
here we are so that was that that was
2012. you probably didn't give it
a second thought eight years later then
what happened
you know as you mentioned i didn't
really give it much thought
um it just kind of came up on my phone
last night and
he replied to it and i didn't even
remember the conversation that we had if
i'm honest
have you replied back to him i have yeah
um i think i think i just said oh just
come over for a couple let me know let
me know if you're about or something
along those lines yeah some famous welsh
hospitality
then you're clearly a ryan reynolds fan
are you a wrexham football club fan
um i wouldn't say i'm a fan um
shamefully like i don't really follow
football
um i mean maybe from now on it will be
and but i know
that i've been to a couple of games with
my dad in the past and i've been around
the sea gym a lot so um
you know it's it's nice to have like
that recognition in wrexham
um as we don't get a lot of attention
really in north east wales so it's
[Music]
brilliant